for those who thought media bias against
Donald Trump would stop after his
election to the presidency Trump's
interview with 16 minutes conclusively
demonstrated just how wrong that idea
was CBS News is Lesley Stahl desperately
attempted to blame Trump for violence
breaking out across the country against
Trump here was what Lesley Stahl had to
say she said quoted has been five full
days since the election and anti-trump
demonstrations driven in part by Hillary
Clinton's edge in the popular vote have
been significant when we interviewed him
on Friday afternoon mr. Trump said he
had not heard about some of the acts of
violence that are propping up in his
name or against his supporters nor had
nor he said had he heard about reports
of racial slurs and personal threats
against african-americans Latinos and
gays by some of his supporters now Trump
you see is ignorant and it's all his
fault meanwhile we in the real world are
all watching mass protests and rioting
on our TV against Trump yet stall work
to make Trump the problem not the
solution here's how their exchange when
Trump said I am very surprised to hear
that I hate to hear that I mean I hate
to hear that and Leslie Stahl said but
do you do hear it and Trump said I don't
hear it I saw i saw one or two instances
leslie stahl on social media Trump but I
think it's a very very small amount
again I think it's leslie stahl do you
want to say anything to those people
Trump I wouldn't say don't do it that
would say don't do it that's terrible
because I'm gonna bring this country
together leslie stahl they're harassing
Latinos and Muslims from I am so
saddened to hear that and I say stop it
if it helps I will say this and I would
say right to the cameras stop it okay so
we don't have stalls original question
to trump but from the content of the
exchange it seems like she focused
almost exclusively on supposed violence
by Trump supporters most of which
appears to be unfounded this is asinine
and it's all so disingenuous stall seems
quite concerned about violence
surrounding Trump selection but CBS News
held the tape of Trump condemning
violence and telling people to cut it
out for three days if they truly cared
about tamping down violence why not
release that tape right away they
release a bunch of other clips from the
interview well that's because the media
don't care about the violence they just
care about blaming Trump for the
violence it's why the media never put
pressure on obama to condemn riots in
cities across the United States even as
Obama and his department of justice
justified them it's why the media never
cared about asking Hillary Clinton about
violence against Trump supporters during
this campaign violence only matters if
it can be blamed on those the left-wing
media hates
otherwise it's a tool for change just
ask media darling DeRay McKesson who was
feeded at the White House or the members
of Occupy Wall Street but if any
Republican goes to a tea party rally
there obviously the problem don't expect
the media to change but if they don't
want to destroy their own credibility
permanently they better start treating
more honestly with the American people
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show ok so much to get to everybody's
getting ready to launch the new Trump
White House will get to the staffing
decisions at the Trump White House in
all of their glory and shame in just a
moment but first we have to say hello to
our friends over at ring com so if you
are concerned about home burglary or the
possibility thereof the thing you should
know is that what burglars often do is
ring the doorbell determine you're not
home and then break into your house ring
calm prevents this they ring the
doorbell and it immediately rings to
your cell phone so you can act like your
home you can also see who's there with
the camera and right now they've
advanced motion detection technology to
protect the entire property with the
ring of security kit right now if you go
to ring and dotcom / ben you get one
hundred and fifty dollars off the ring
of security kit ring is one of the
advertisers that we use where I've
actually spent my own money on their
products because I think their product
is so stellar its ring calm / Ben again
150 bucks off your ring of security kit
and stops burglaries and and allows you
to know who's at your front door which
is always something that is worthwhile
particularly for me since I have heard
that Steve Bannon is coming in any case
we can jump right into let's jump right
into the news okay so at the beginning
let's just say it is fun to watch the
left meltdown it is really a lot of fun
to watch the left lose their minds and
what makes it fun for me is the
knowledge that the left would lose their
minds the exact same way if Ted Cruz had
one or Marco Rubio or one or hell of
John Kasich and one they would still
lose their minds and go crazy so there's
a lot of talk about Trump being out of
the box I agree there's a lot of talk
about Trump being uniquely bad in some
ways i agree but that's not why the left
is protesting the left is protesting
because they don't like the idea that
conservatives even showed up to vote
they don't like the idea that somebody
who's not a democrat at least a name
actually is the president of the united
states and so they're going now so here
is a little bit of footage from some of
these protests this was the scene in
downtown los angeles for the third
straight
night angry Angelenos taking over the
streets and protest a president elect
Donald Trump's victory in Tuesday's
election we more than 180 people were
arrested in what became a dangerous
situation for some officers we didn't
have an officer who was injured when
trying to take someone into custody that
officer was transported to a local
hospital and at this time he's in stable
condition and he's expected to be
released later today LAPD saying those
they arrested had interfered with
traffic and vandalized public property
including buildings and patrol vehicles
the group growing to several hundred in
size we want our voices to be heard and
we will not stand down there were even
some reports of people throwing rocks
and bottles and officers and
demonstrators who according to police
just wouldn't go home oh my god there's
no case we stopped it there so these
idiots take over the streets in LA to
which from says I drink your cell too
bitter to use their delicious like
Donald Trump is going to resign the
presidency because a couple of whiny
college students from LA decide to take
over a street in a city the Trump lost
every vote in like all these riots all
these protests are taking place in areas
where Trump loss right it's not like
there's any impact on Trump it's not
like there's any impact on on the
administration I'm not even sure what
they're protesting at this point like
there's lots of stuff that Trump is
going to do that's probably worthy of
protest but hadn't done it yet he hasn't
done it yeah like maybe later tonight
I'll lead a protest against Steve
bandhan becoming the White House chief
counsel whatever he is but like he
hasn't done anything yet this is all
this is all silly talk so that all these
all these winding cry babies who are
very very upset and they're walking
around all mopey and oh my god the world
is over because someone they don't like
was elected president he hasn't done
anything yet he's not even the president
yet he's just some guy who's getting
ready to be President once he's
president then I think that it is fair
if you disapprove a policy that he's
pushing you go out and you can you can
protest all the never riot don't take
over streets because this makes you a
douche but if you're going to do this on
the basis of I lost an election well
maybe more of you young people should
have showed up and actually voted in
that election and then maybe wouldn'ta
lost I mean Hillary Clinton won the
popular vote but you lost in a lot of
these swing states because young people
stayed home smoking weed so young people
didn't show up for her minorities in
show up for her who are the people who
are actually riding and protesting
largely young people and minorities so
the whole thing is just ridiculous
naturally Cory Booker who thinks he's
going to run for president in 2020
against Trump he's trying to to make
inroads with these protesters hoping to
jazz them up get some enthusiasm going
I'm sitting here right now having this
conversation with you because of the
tradition of American protest I have my
rights not because of Washington
suddenly deciding Strom Thurmond and
others hey let's give a certain
Americans equal rights but because of
the ardent unyielding voice of
protesters and so when you have a
president that is in his campaign who
ran saying things that not aren't is
contrary to a fact but literally
threatening to use presidential power in
a way that would erode the rights and
privileges inequality of large sections
of Americans god bless the protesters
but I will tell you this i caution
anyone who in their protest becomes the
very thing that they're protesting
against thing turning to hateful spin
then he says they keep saying loves or a
love Trump's hate and then they go and
burn crap and he's saying that's
probably a bad idea yeah probably okay
so here okay so before we go any further
I think that it's important to get but
get past the elephant in the room
because I know there are a lot of people
watching specifically because of the
news that Steve ban and the former
Breitbart CEO is now going to be the the
Trump White House chief he's not the
chief of staff he's the chief strategist
is what they're calling him which means
that he's basically Valerie Jarrett or
Karl Rove it means he has a very heavy
portion in the in the policy-making and
the direction of the of the
administration so I've written columns
about what I think of Steve I
legitimately think that Steve bandhan is
one of the worst people of America but
that doesn't mean that this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to the
country that he's the that he's the
White House chief strategist I'll
explain what's what's good about this
and what's bad about this and what he's
actually going to do and a lot of it is
still up in the air now I will say the
left are going too far in this so
they're immediately saying that he is
that he is anti-semitic they're saying
that Steve is white supremacist you have
all these people who are who are saying
that Steve is white nationalist ok so
there's Steve's personal views and then
there's who Steve associates with
Steve's been who he's willing to humor I
have no evidence on
personal level and I work with you for
years I have no evidence on a personal
level that Steve's a racist or an
anti-semite okay I've never heard those
views come from him I've never felt
anti-semitism from Steve okay and that
said so the left is going too far when
they say like there's a big headline at
Huffington Post white nationalist runs
White House okay that's that's too much
it's not it's not true that said there
are some problems here there are some
problems here and here are the problems
so i have a few thoughts on on bandhan
as the White House chief strategist
beyond the fact that i think the benin
is a brutal vindictive piece of crap
beyond that I think that when it comes
to bandon the number one question I've
gotten texts and questions all days
yantis American racist as I said I have
no personal knowledge of him personally
being anti-semitic and racist that said
he obviously has pandered to the
anti-semitic racist all right the all
tripe is group of ppl right is a group
of people first of all let me just say
something about the alt right not
everyone who says they're all right is
actually all right there are a lot of
people who don't know what it means they
don't know the founding philosophy and
ideology of the all right they just
think all right means that you like to
put up Pepe memes or like to tweet about
Harambee or whatever other stupid thing
you're doing online and you don't like
Paul Ryan and therefore you're all right
that's not what all right means all
right is a philosophy that is that is
expositor by people ranging from vox Dei
to Richard Spencer and that philosophy
is that Western culture is inseparable
from European ethnicity okay it is white
nationalism all right is white
nationalism that's what the that's what
the the root of the philosophy is that
doesn't mean that everybody identifying
is alright believes that some of them
are doing it wrong but it does mean that
that is the root of the philosophy and
Bannon knows that he's not a stupid man
and he has pander to those people he had
my logia napolis who's an all try
popularizer write a long piece for
Breitbart about how the alt right was
the kind of new legit new right in the
United States and the actual white
supremacists duel of Benin and they
think the Bandon BAM abandon bragged
openly about turning Breitbart into an
alt right fansite essentially Richard
Spencer who's an actual white
supremacist he said bright bart has
elective affinities with the alt right
and the alt right has clearly influenced
Breitbart in this way Breitbart has
acted as a gateway to all right ideas
and writers I don't think it has done
this liberally again it's a matter of
elective infinities affinities and I
think that's exactly right I think that
Spencer is correct praetor brim lo
another one he said the ban and being
appointed to the Trump campaign
was great news okay so what does that
mean what does that mean that Bannon has
elective affinities with the all right
that he's warm toward a bunch of white
supremacists in anti-semites and and he
is warm toward the philosophy of the
intellectualized all right what does
that mean well it depends on what you
think Ben is actually going to be doing
at the White House so what does he want
well Bannon always wants power well now
he finally has he spent a decade
accruing power he kept kind of leaping
from politician to politician riding
their coattails he did to Michelle
Bachman he made a documentary about her
and then he hoped to kind of glom onto
her success he did the same thing with
sarah palin he did the same thing with
Andrew Breitbart before he died then
took over his business and now he's done
the same thing with Trump and he just
picked two winners in a row Breitbart
and Trump and so he ends up in one of
the most powerful positions in American
government so what will he do well first
of all he will actually target enemies
Bannon is a deeply deeply vindictive guy
he's somebody who likes to destroy
enemies it's something he takes pleasure
in he likes to think of himself that way
so he wouldn't be a surprise for me to
say this even to him and and so when I
jokingly said earlier this year that if
Trump wins I expect my IRS audit that
was not really a joke I mean I think
that if it with bandhan in the White
House I think a lot of people who did
not support Trump sufficiently and
didn't support Bannon and think bannon's
a bad guy those people will will be
targeted by Bannon or at least there's a
good shot they will be but more
importantly beyond sort of personal
vendettas bannon's actual agenda is he
does not like the Republican Party which
is okay except that he doesn't like them
for the wrong reasons Bannon is a is a
European far-right populace that's what
Bannon is he's somebody who believes
first and foremost in the idea that we
have to have tariffs and we have to
assure the continuation of Western
civilization by limiting immigration not
just immigration on the basis of
philosophy just immigration generally
has to be limited he doesn't believe in
small government per se that's not an
important thing to him he's he's sort of
in line with marine lepen the french
national party leader she calls for
harsher penalties for criminals and
significant restrictions on Muslim
immigration and protectionism on trade
and a restoration of the frunk is the
national currency rather than the euro
and big government in terms of health
care that's pretty much Trump's platform
and bandhan is all in favor of that the
European right is not the American right
the American right traditionally the
conservative American right
traditionally has said constitutional
principles like individual liberty and
personal responsibility and limited
government these are the core
americanism and if you can accept those
principles you can come from anywhere
and be part of America that's not what
the Nationalists right believes
nationalist right believes closed the
borders now we have to stand up for our
culture against all other cultures and
people can't really integrate into the
culture in there there can't be any
integration there can't be any openness
how we really have to close ourselves
off it's very close to sort of pat
buchanan zai dia of the universe and
it's no shock that the Daily Beast
reported the bandit has already reached
out to marine lepen in France as well as
Nigel Farage with the UK independent
party so the question is what will
Bannon actually do so at the same time
they announced the Bandon was going to
be the new White House chief strategist
they announced that Ryan's Priebus was
going to be that Ryan's previous was
going to be the White House chief of
staff so there are a few ways to read
that there's the optimistic way to read
that and then there's the pessimistic
way to read that and I'll let you choose
and by the way I'm trying to be as
objective as I possibly can be given the
fact that I have personal distaste for a
man that I believe is a destructive
force inside the Republican Party and in
the conservative movement generally and
who's out for his own
self-aggrandizement here's here's the
breakdown if you're optimistic bandon
leads the war on the media right he just
fights the left media on behalf of
Donald Trump because that's sort of what
he did at Breitbart and Ryan's handles
all of the internal party squabble and
just helps Trump work with Ryan because
Ryan's is very very close with Speaker
of the House Paul Ryan that's the most
optimistic version that sort of what ed
morrissey thinks is happening here I
don't think that's what's happening here
there are other people who say the
Bandon was just added as a stop to the
populace base really rinds Priebus is
going to be doing the heavy lifting I
don't think that's right either and the
reason I don't think that's right either
is because it seems to me that Ryan's is
the week is the week leg of the stool
Bannon is an alpha riences of beta
Bryan's is the bagman and ban and his
whispering and Trump's ear this morning
rinds came out and he was praising
trumpet praising Bannon and and here is
what he had to say about vanden a lot of
people are concerned because they look
at the website he ran Breitbart news as
one paper put it it recently accused
President Obama of quote importing more
hating Muslims called bill kristol a
renegade jus advised female victims of
online harassment to just log off and
stop screwing up the internet for men I
I guess people are wondering is this the
world view that Steve Bannon will bring
to the White House can you let them know
anything about him that would be
contrary to the website he ran sure and
and and that wasn't his writing I mean
that was that was some articles and
bright but I wasn't him okay back it was
having the buck stops a guy I know oh
yeah the guy I know is a guy that isn't
any of those things I mean the guy knows
the guy sit in an office all day
yesterday talking about hiring talking
about people and in the last few months
as a guide exhibit none of those
qualities here's a guy who's Harvard
Business School he was a ten-year naval
officer London School of Economics I
believe he is he is a guy who is pretty
he's very very smart very temperate and
together we've been able to manage but
then said this is is to put it bluntly
this is a load of horse bleep ok this is
what what he's saying right now is
natural okay Bannon went at Breitbart
all the buck to absolutely stopped
abandoned no major piece went up on the
website with bit without bannon's go
ahead and and that's been true for a
long time and people have been saying
that for a long time it's true okay so
the idea that ban and had nothing to do
with you know that the transitions were
Trump's tourism and the alt right is
absolutely untrue when he says the ban
in his temperate that's just insane okay
like I don't know a single person who
knows ban and who would describe man in
his temperate Benin can be temperate he
can be charming with people who he
thinks he's he's conning basically and
rights since he spent this entire
election cycle massaging Trump's
buttocks and the people of those around
him it's not a surprise that the abandon
was tempered with him why wouldn't he be
but but Bryan's has to know he's lying i
mean i can't imagine that Ryan's has
gone this entire election cycle with how
abandon screaming at him at least blonds
that's not the temperate is not the word
it's just it's just absurd all the way
through and this is the problem right so
the left is right is wrong about bandhan
but the idea that man is not going to
have any any say in this White House is
really not true and when it comes to how
that breaks down the problem is of
course that abandoned wants to go to war
with Ryan like literally an hour after
they announced the Bandon would be
working with Ryan's at the at the White
House Breitbart ran a story about how
Ryan should be ousted as Speaker of the
House if you think that the band
just gonna sit by while all the policy
gets done yeah that's that's not
happening and Kellyanne Conway who
really has turned out to be hey I
thought this during the campaign but she
is she's a very very skilled liar she
talked up bandhan as well on Meet the
Press it was a very small coercing your
team probably less than 10 people all
told and and I'm sure that everyone will
be very important to the president
moving forward I will say this though I
think we're having worked with him and
known him but Steve benen in this
particular campaign was the general and
he is much more the goldman sachs
managing partner and much more the naval
officer i think than people realize then
people realize that's what you're saying
is he's not we wouldn't come in to say
let's burn Washington down / verbally I
think that the president-elect is there
to actually implement his first 100-day
plan and those around him know that and
will appreciate that whether it's within
his inner circle on Capitol Hill I look
we are very grateful in Trump world to
both Bannon and previous and I think
you'll see them work continue to work
together we all worked very closely it's
a very sorry okay so look people are not
gonna be in the mood to hear bad stuff
about Trump right now which is why I'm
trying to be honest about what I think
this means I'll wait to see how it
shakes out but the idea that's being
promulgated that Steve is some sort of
temperate moderate moderating force in
the in the White House that just is not
true it's just not true and if you want
lies then I suggest that you listen to
some other show or watch some other show
but I'm not gonna lie to you just
because Trump won so I'll tell we're
gonna do some serious good Trump bad
Trump in a minute because Trump it's not
all bad i think the rinds pic is a good
Peck I think that that this pic is a bad
pic but we'll get to all that in just a
second but to do that see the rest you
have to go over today lee weyer calm and
subscribe eight dollars a month you get
subscription today lee weyer that means
you can watch the rest of this show live
it means that you can also if you
subscribe right now you get i think the
the first three months of the entire
website without ads which is pretty cool
and if you're an annual subscriber then
you can still get my new novel two
religions signed by me which is pretty
neat i'll so you get clave ins podcast
get to be part of the mailbag so lots of
goodies if you go to daily wire.com
right now become part of the largest
podcast largest conservative podcast in
the united states
you